aucun élu ne pense ni ne dit d'ailleurs
que la taxe foncière est un impôt d'État
aucun les taux de taxes foncières qu'ell
soit bâti ou non bâti sont effectivement
et fort heureusement encore voté en
conseil
municipal c'est même le dernier levé
fiscal restant aux communes après le
véritable holdup en règle commis sur la
taxe d'habitation en violation totale
que vous le vouliez ou non avec l'esprit
de l'article 72 de notre Constitution et
du principe même de libre administration
des communes qui nous est si cher ici au
Sénat et qui va le
rester mais dans un contexte financier
extrêmement difficile pour les communes
augmentation entre l'inflation et les
baisses de dotation d'État
l'augmentation des fluides la PR
prolifération normative les péréquations
de tout poil sans parler du FS Rif c'est
malheureusement pour certains élus
locaux l'unique moyen pour maintenir un
niveau de service public satisfaisant
dans leur commune et donc de maintenir
la cohésion sociale tellement nécessaire
dans un pays autant
fracturé j'ajoute que cette décision
d'augmentation de taxes foncières prise
par seulement 14 % des 35000 communes de
France sont généralement mesurées et
calculé afin que la charge fiscale
globale des ménages reste inférieure à
ce qu'elle était avant la disparition de
la taxe d'habitation avec pour objectif
essentiel de préserver la qualité des
services publics tout en maintenant la
dette à un faible niveau et en
poursuivant un programme
d'investissement durable bref en somme
les principes de base d'une saine
gestion à l'œuvre dans nos
communes en vérité le sujet central que
révèle cette insupportable polémique
c'est que nous constatons amèrement les
effets délétaires du phénomène de
recentralisation massive qui frappe de
plein fouet nos collectivités et que les
maires n'ont plus qu'un seul levier
fiscal pour y faire face la taxe
foncière alors je remercie nos collègues
du groupe CRCE et kanaki et notamment
salvoldedi d'avoir organisé ce
débat et alors que le chef de l'État
quand il sera en capacité d'équilibrer
les budgets de notre pays une contrainte
qui elle s'impose rigoureusement au
maire il pourra éventuellement venir
nous donner des leçons mais pas avant
merci de votre attention merci Monsieur
Hugonet monsieur le ministre on va
attendre que Monsieur Gonet promptement
rejoint ses rangs voilà monsieur le
ministre pour pour 2 minutes oui merci
Madame la la présidente monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur j'ai j'ai
l'impression que peut-être avec un peu
de malice vous passer de l'autonomie
financière à l'autonomie fiscale quand
on supprime la taxe d'habitation et
qu'on la compense on ne rond pas le
principe qui garantit l'autonomie
financière telle qu'elle est prévue par
l'article 72 de la Constitution parce
qu'on garde on garantit les ressources
et c'est pas l'autonomie fiscale qui est
garantie c'est l'autonomie financière et
je pense que vous le savez euh
pertinemment après vous me dites alors
je trouve que c'est très illustratif du
débat qu'on a les maires qui ont
augmenté la taxe foncière ont fait de
telle sorte que elles ne viennent pas
complètement euh venir à la hauteur de
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
mais la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation a été faite pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat elle a pas été faite
pour permettre aux maèr d'augmenter la
taxe foncière et on est là dans ce débat
euh parfois un peu de Sour en disant
mais la taxe foncière sa haosse ne peut
jamais être justifiée par une
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
a été compensé à l'euro prè il faut donc
renvoyer un débat purement local un
débat purement local et moi ça me va
bien comme ça parce que je pense c'est
une fiscalité locale et non pas des
décisions nationales qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les décisions ou pas
d'augmentation des taux très bien
monsieur Hugonet pour une minute
monsieur le ministre sauf votre
respect c'est un dialogue de Sour
effectivement j'aimerais que vous
puissiez mettre vos grandes compétences
réellement au service des communes
monsieur je vous le dis très sincèrement
comme un élu qui a 25 ans de mandat
derrière lui comme peut-être beaucoup
d'autres collègues ici je vous le dis
vous êtes en décalage profond cette
espèce de cûp de bonne taux qui a été
fait avec la taxe d'habitation n'a
personne n'a été dupe de ce qui s'est
passé et contrairement à ce que vous
dites ce n'est pas rendre du pouvoir
d'achat ça c'était le holdup politique
la réalité des faits c'est que nous
croulons sous les taxes à moins qu'on ne
vive pas dans le même pays et croyez-moi
dans nos communes nous ne vivons pas la
même chose que vous ce que vous exposez
qui peut être brillant qui est
certainement verbal je vous le dis et
sortez sortez de votre ministère pour
aller exactement voir dans nos
territoires quel qu'il soit où nous en
sommes monsieur min merci Monsieur
Hugonet